alright let's open up the March edition
of Funko's smugglers bounty is a Star
Wars fungal product this is all
exclusive this is a monthly this is a
bi-monthly every other month you get
this 25 bucks every other month or one
box $25 box alright so there is always a
pin head fill up there just was so does
it begin dan has eyes ain't say I'm here
it prices in here there is actually
translation portal 2 star wars I think
it's called art edition Parker something
like that so I'm sorry don't yell with
me if I'm getting right so you go you
get a pin these are nice thick solid
pins those are cool there is also a
catch so all of the Funko boxes have
patches and we have pork burrito burrito
did not shoot first he said you should a
shot first needs maybe still feel like
there is always late t-shirts so this
one see alright this says one code
guttural I they should put a galactic
empire which is Han Solo wanted for
smuggling that are alive just for
smuggling coke we have tonight we have a
little bit Ibaka
we have been Kenobi this is exclusive
what is exclusive about it i'm gonna
choose maybe let the pose yeah because
there's a regular been alright we got
something else pretty big we got chu of
them red snaggletooth Oh to write cycle
too good I won't they should have made a
blue snaggletooth you know your action
figure history but did you have a little
taller so I do like how he does have
like a shorter body because he's good
and he's got the snaggle tooth that's
that's really cool I under-rated
character and is that it that is it okay
what else do you need you gotta to
Funko's these are you know they sell for
ten dollars each they're exclusive you
can sell these for more don't sell them
keep them get your pin you got your
patch it constantly got your shirt all
of this for twenty-five dollars so you
go to salons bonny kept calm a lot of
cool stuff you like Star Wars like Bunco
let us know what you think thanks for
watching we'll do this again a couple
months